- [Instructor] The
Pre-equilibrium Approximation
is used to find the rate law
for a mechanism with a fast initial step.
As an example, let's look
at the reaction between
nitric oxide and bromine.
In the first step of the mechanism,
nitric oxide combines with
bromine to form NOBr2.
And in the second step of the mechanism,
NOBr2 reacts with NO to
form our product 2NOBr.
NOBr2 is generated
from the first elementary
step of the mechanism.
And then NOBr2 is used
up in the second step.
Since NOBr2 wasn't there in the beginning
and it's not there in the end,
we call NOBr2 an intermediate.
The first step of the mechanism is fast.
And the second step of
the mechanism is slow.
Since the second step of
the mechanism is slow,
this is the rate determining step.
And we can write the rate
law for the overall reaction
by writing the rate law for
this elementary reaction
that makes up step two of our mechanism.
So we can write the rate
of reaction is equal to
for step two, our rate constant is K2.
And we multiply K2, the rate constant,
by the concentration of our two reactants,
which would be the concentration of NOBr2,
and the concentration of NO.
Since the coefficients
in our balanced equation
are ones for NOBr2 and
one and a one for NO,
we can take the coefficients
and turn them into
exponents in our rate law.
So we can do this because this
is an elementary reaction.
However, we can't leave the rate law
for the overall reaction,
in terms of the concentration
of our intermediate, NOBr2.
It's preferable to have rate laws
written in terms of the
concentration of our reactants,
which were NO and Br2.
So we need some way of substituting N
for the concentration of NOBr2.
And we can do that by assuming that
the first elementary step in our mechanism
comes to a fast equilibrium.
So if we assume the first step
comes to a fast equilibrium,
we can use the
Pre-equilibrium Approximation.
If we assume that the first step
comes to a fast equilibrium,
or a pre equilibrium,
we know at equilibrium,
the rate of the forward reaction
is equal to the rate of
the reverse reaction.
So in the forward reaction for step one,
NO combines with Br2 to form NOBr2.
And in the reverse reaction,
NOBr2 breaks apart to form NO and Br2.
So if the rate of the forward reaction
is equal to the rate of the
reverse reaction at equilibrium,
let's go ahead and write the rate laws
for the forward and the reverse reaction.
The rate constant for the
forward reaction is K1.
So we can go ahead and write
the rate of the forward
reaction is equal to K1.
And our two reactants are NO and Br2.
So we have K1 times the
concentration of NO,
times the concentration of Br2.
Since the coefficients
in our balanced equation
are both ones for these two reactants,
we can raise the power of
these two concentrations
to the first power.
Since this is an elementary
reaction, we can do this.
And we set this rate
of the forward reaction
equal to the rate of the reverse reaction.
The reverse reaction has a
rate constant of K minus one,
and we have only NOBr2 with
a coefficient of one in it.
So we multiply K minus one
times the concentration of
NOBr2, to the first power.
Next, our goal is to substitute N
for the concentration of our intermediate.
And so we can divide both sides
of the equation by K minus one.
So if we decide if we divide
both sides of the equation by K minus one,
on the right side, K
minus one cancels out.
And we get that the concentration
of our intermediate NOBr2,
is equal to K one
times the concentration
of NO to the first power,
of Br2 to the first power,
divided by K minus one.
Next, we can substitute all of this in
for the concentration of our intermediate.
That gives us the rate
of reaction is equal to,
we still have this K2 in here,
so we need to make sure to include it.
And we're gonna substitute everything in
all of this in for the
concentration of our intermediate.
So that would be times K one,
times the concentration
of NO to the first power,
of Br2 to the first power,
divided by K minus one.
And then we still have this
concentration of NO to the first power.
So we have to make sure to
include that in our rate law.
Let's think about what we would get
if we multiply two constants together
and then divide by a third constant.
So multiplying K2 times K1,
and then we divide by K minus one,
that would just give us another constant,
which we could just call K.
So K is now the rate constant
for the overall reaction.
So we have the rate law
for the overall reaction
is equal to K,
times the concentration of
we have NO to the first power
times NO to the first power,
which is just the concentration
of NO to the second power.
And we still have to include
the concentration of
bromine to the first power.
So now we have a rate law
for our overall reaction
in terms of the concentration
of our two reactants.
The rate of reaction is
equal to the rate constant K,
times the concentration of NO squared,
times the concentration of
bromine to the first power.
The experimentally determined rate law
matches the rate law that we found
using the Pre-equilibrium Approximation.
And if you look at the coefficients
for the overall equation,
there's a two in front of NO
and a one in front of Br2,
it might be tempting just to say,
"Can't we just take those coefficients
and turn them into exponents,
because in this case,
they happen to match the
exponent in our rate law?"
That's just a coincidence
for this reaction.
We can't just take the coefficients
for an overall equation
and turn them into
exponents in the rate law.
We can only do that for
elementary reactions.
Like the elementary reactions
in the two steps of our mechanism.
It's important to point out
that if the rate of the forward reaction
is equal to the rate of
the reverse reaction,
the concentration of our intermediate,
NOBr2 remains constant.
And therefore we can use this
Pre-equilibrium Approximation
to find the rate law for a reaction
with a fast initial step.